c'est un garçon très sexuel et très
active ouais non mais on peut être très
sexuel sans faire des enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc elle a dit que c'était très
difficile sa situation et c'est vrai que
ça choqué pas mal de personnes derrière
ce qu'on peut comprendre surtout quand
on a un peu les salaires pour The Voice
combien il gagne sur The Voice elle
gagne à peu près 450 000 € de cachet et
un petit peu plus avec les droits
d'image donc on est proche de 500000 €.
voilà à ça on ajoute les disques ah oui
là ça c'est plus d'un million de disques
et elle touche combien par disque elle
touche 79 centimes d'euro après ça
grimpe c'est exponentiel en fonction du
nombre de ventes ça veut dire que si je
fais le calcul on est à peu près entre
50 et 70 000 € par mois voilà ça c'est à
dire que même une année ou pas on peut
comprendre que ça agacé les gens on
appartient de combien pour vous on est
riche parti de combien par mois 10 15000
€ par mois
j'aimerais bien oui mais à partir de
combien on est riche pour toi on est
riche au-dessus de 100 000 non par mois
pas moi oui
4000 4000 comme François Hollande
quand tu gagnes 4000 € par mois tu fais
partie du plus petit pourcentage de
français
il peut pas non plus tout faire
ça me manque d'être [ __ ]
sur Instagram elle est elle a affirmée
aujourd'hui je ne vais être normal ne
plus mettre au faux-ongles plus de
coloration plus de make-up plus rien
abstinence totale sa maman tellement
d'être une quand même voilà c'était pour
te faire plaisir parce que je sais que
tu aimes tous ces gens d'Instagram
nuance voilà je l'avais vu à Miami
pour les anges comme ça et c'était la
saison il était là-bas elle m'avait
chauffé de ouf mais non
[Musique]
je comprends pas dans sa façon de
s'habiller non je voulais dire
on peut rien faire déjà je pense que
j'étais maquillé enfin je pense et en
plus on ne peut rien faire c'est que
vous avez des caméras partout c'est ce
qui est incroyable c'est que vous
marchez dans dans l'appartement c'est
une super maison bord de l'eau là passer
derrière un poteau vous savez que
derrière un poteau il y a quelqu'un qui
est en train de filmer ou pas à côté
d'un d'un mur où il y a un rideau vous
donnez un coup et donc quelqu'un m'a dit
parce qu'il y a quelqu'un derrière
voilà Coolio et je rappelle donc Coolio
était il était justement de 59 ans et
jeudi soir il était découvert mort dans
sa salle de bain la salle de bain d'un
ami pardon à Los Angeles personne ne
saigne un rapport toxicologique qui a
été fait mais pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore les les données donc on sait pas
du tout s'il y avait de la drogue de
l'alcool on ne sait pas du tout est-ce
que tu en sais un peu plus d'alcool il
buvait pas
il a peut-être vraiment eu une crise
cardiaque c'est possible avec une vie
aussi intense peut-être à 59 ans oui
parce que il faisait pas d'alcool
mais bon donc là il a été trouvé dans la
salle de bain d'un de ses amis c'était
où à Los Angeles
il refusait son passeport en fait et
donc il était resté là-bas temps de
récupérer le passeport et voilà d'accord
c'est quand la dernière fois que tu l'as
vu que tu l'as parlé toi il y a pas très
longtemps en fait au mois d'avril
j'étais à Miami il avait vu sur ma story
que j'étais à Miami et
c'est quelqu'un qui est très intense qui
me dit je vais vous lire en français je
sais que tu es là il faut absolument
qu'on se voit mais je lui dis mais non
je suis pas coiffée
on s'est vu au palme sur Sao the beach
le Palm motel bah restaurant et puis on
a passé de 16h jusque jusque quatre
heures
vous êtes qui vous je vous connaissez
quel est votre prénom on est désolé bébé
alors je te dis tout elle est vendeuse
chez arabes on avait on avait un trou
dans l'émission on avait un trou dans
l'émission
j'adore cette question vous êtes qui
non je vous ai jamais vu en disant de on
ne sait jamais vu d'accord mais vous
m'avez vu aujourd'hui alors vous avez
des émissions culturelles tu te
présentes avant de poser ta question on
sait jamais croisé parce qu'avant je
faisais des émissions extrêmement
culturelles d'accord
je m'appelle Sophie Coste la question
c'est vous n'avez jamais envie de faire
un enfant avec lui parce que il a
tellement enfin on a l'impression qu'il
a la patate cet homme-là pardon on a
l'impression qu'il a la paternité
c'est un garçon très sexuel et très
actif oui non mais on peut être très
sexuel sans faire des enfants
Candice et Inès deux danseuses qui
seraient jalouses de la popularité
d'elsabois c'est celle qui avait dansé
avec Michou souvenez-vous qui du coup et
maintenant hyper populaire fauve a pris
la défense d'Els à bois elle a traité
Candice Pascal et Inès Van Damme de
gamine et maintenant elles sont lâchées
et il y a deux équipes il y a l'équipe
de fauve l'équipe d'alsabois elle ne
peuvent pas s'encaisser vos photos et
payer 60 000 € pour la saison Candice
Pascal Christophe Licata Inès Van Damme
40000 Katrina Patchett Anthony Colette
30000 Adrien Kaby Jordan mouillerai
25000 et Pierre Mauduit et calissons
pourquoi 15000 donc ça va être 15 à
60000 est-ce que vous trouvez ça
choquant ou pas qu'elle soit mise en
avant par la prod et qu'on lui donne
finalement le meilleur danseur pour
qu'elle gagne oui donc non c'est normal
j'ai fait des trucs avec photo tous les
gens dans la rue ils m'ont des
autographes elle adore elle est
extrêmement sympa c'est une fille
chouette
ça veut dire que du coup ça veut dire
pour les téléspectateurs on sait
maintenant que quand fauve danse et ben
c'est d'ailleurs qui a gagné
parce que il suffit de se souvenir du
palmarès de Danse avec les stars Laurent
maistret Ryan bensetti c'était pas des
Billy Crawford c'était pas des rois de
la danse le deuxième d'accord il n'a pas
gagné ils n'ont pas gagné à chaque fois
et aussi un truc très important qui va
dans le sens de ce que dit Laurent c'est
que Fauve Hautot elle est favorisée par
son talent c'est une star elle fait de
la fiction elle est depuis peu les gérée
elle a dit charisme elle est pas plus de
talent on fait de la fiction c'est les
gérer d'une marque de cosmétique
japonais sur Instagram elle a fait
partie du jury Danse avec les stars
c'est la seule mais non c'est pas
favorisée elle a plus de talent que les
autres
mais il y a quelques années c'est Will
Smith qui avait partagé sa coloscopie en
2019 il est posté une vidéo de 18
minutes lui c'était pour faire plutôt un
petit truc un peu marrant il avait dit
voilà je parie que sur Youtube je
pourrai pas faire 50 millions de
followers si je monte mon cul
[Musique]
juste pour vous dire avant de donner la
parole pour ceux qui ne l'ont jamais
fait et qui sont jeunes à partir de 50
ans on le fait vous avez vérité j'ai
déjà fait il faut il y a une préparation
qu'on prend 48 heures avant je vous
passe les détails pour vous vider et que
vous soyez que ce soit nickel à
l'intérieur pour qu'on puisse voir et si
par hasard vous l'avez mal fait il boit
pas donc il vous dit que tu payes quand
même mais on n'a rien vu de recommencer
c'était le cas le Will Smith qui avait
mal fait pas donc non seulement il a été
un peu ridicule mais enfin Will Smith
pour tout le monde maintenant c'est un
mec qui a mis une baffe et qui est plein
de merde voilà c'est un peu du bien et
pardon ça vous dérange en quoi Mathieu
j'ai pas compris en fait ce qui vous
gêne par rapport à ça parce que vous
dites finalement oui c'est parce que moi
je pense que j'ai un peu comme Jean-Mi
je pense qu'une star c'est une star une
star c'est quelqu'un moi j'habite dans
un coin où il y a Johnny qui est pas
loin tu vois et ben on la voit jamais
elle est pas au Monoprix elle fait
passer course elle va pas aux toilettes
elle fait pas de coloscopie elle est pas
malade une star c'est une star si demain
elle faisait ses courses comme ça
qu'elle pète qu'elle machin et tout je
jure une star je veux pas savoir que
vous discute des problèmes de merde